-You guys, the midterm elections
are on Tuesday,
and there are concerns
that low voter turnout
will affect the Democrats'
chances of taking back Congress.
It's scary to think about Trump
continuing for two more years
without any checks and balances.
So here with a kick-ass song
that's going to
make everyone vote,
please welcome a fuzzy little
kitten named Liberty
and one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -On November 6th
we'll be in the same place ♪
♪ At the ballot box
with a happy look on our face ♪
♪ Knowing that we're stopping
this here country ♪
♪ From going to the [bleep] ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Get registered and vote ♪
♪ This here song is my plea ♪
♪ I'm begging you
on behalf of Liberty ♪
♪ 'Cause if you don't vote,
I'll [bleep] kill this kitten ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Amber --
-Somebody's got to do something!
This election is too important!
♪ This wasn't the best way
to make new friends ♪
♪ But there'll be no time
for hanging ♪
♪ When the world frigging ends ♪
♪ So vote right now ♪
♪ Or I'll throw this
little kitten in a blender ♪
-Amber, Amber, this is --
-We tried your "Closer Look"
crap! It doesn't work!
♪ If you don't vote
this will be the end ♪
♪ Say goodbye to your cute
little furry friend ♪
♪ 'Cause I swear to God ♪
♪ I'll flush him
right down the toilet ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ So if you don't vote,
then say goodbye ♪
♪ I'm gonna shoot this tiny baby
up into the sky ♪
♪ I'll strap his little body to
a rocket and blow him to bits ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Please try to understand
I'm a desperate woman ♪
♪ Vote or I'll get him
addicted to tobacco ♪
♪ He'll be a smoker ♪
♪ It's a long, slow death ♪
♪ 2, 3, 4 ♪
♪ If you vote, then Liberty
will be your friend ♪
♪ If you don't, I swear to God
you'll never see him again ♪
♪ So vote right now ♪
♪ Or I'll feed him poison
wrapped inside a hot dog ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ This song was just a joke ♪
♪ The cat is fine ♪
♪ We just want you to vote
but your country might not be ♪
♪ Vote in the midterms ♪
♪ Or it will be the figurative ♪
♪ Not literal death of
the concept, not the cat ♪
♪ Who was fine but the state of
being free called libertyyyyy ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go vote!
-Amber and Liberty, everybody.